(crowd cheers and applauds)
- You look very cute and beautiful.
- I love the fall.
- We're tonal today.
Do you see how we're-
- Look, we didn't even
call each other.
- I know!
- Yes. You were feeling earth tones.
I was feeling, how are your chickens?
Last time you were here,
we were talking about your chickens.
- Let's get to the serious stuff
right away.
- Let's just get right
to the nitty gritty, yes.
- Well, the chickens moved
to the family farm in Oklahoma.
- Oh, my bunnies I talked to
you about now live in Montana.
My ranch in Montana.
- Yes. Okay.
- Yes. It's better for them.
- They're happier.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And yes, each of them went-
- Space.
- And I felt a little
bit guilty about this,
but each of them went in
their own little to-go box.
(crowd laughs)
I was a little bit like, don't think
too much about this, chickens.
- Yeah. You're not nuggets. It's fine.
- Yeah. You're not a nugget.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- And they all had a little
bit of food on the plane
with a little bit of Benadryl in there.
(crowd, Kelly, and Jennifer laugh)
- But there's a tiny bit of help.
I love that though. That's
fun, living on a farm.
That's better for them as well.
- Yeah. Yes. They don't lay eggs anymore.
- Yeah, after a certain age-
- They're post menopausal.
- Yeah, yeah.
(crowd laughs)
- Um, but you know what?
- The world doesn't care
about them anymore.
- They still have value.
I know. But they still have value
and they're still smart, lovely ladies.
- They are relevant. They are relevant.